et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
sur le plateau avec bahreïn où mon
source chercheur associé à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'algérie monsieur
mansour bienvenu.merci alors abdelmajid
tebboune qui affirment soutenir le
mouvement populaire le irak
une journée nationale a même été
institué pour ce mouvement
quel message en faisant cela veut-il
faire passer à la population bien sûr ce
sont des gestes d'apaisement des appels
d'apaisement que le président actuel
non son verre en verre en vers leur la
converse la société civile mobilisés
depuis un an aujourd'hui donc qui fêtera
le rat qui fêtera son anniversaire
demain
la pression se maintient je crois qu'ils
les dirigeants aujourd'hui en conscience
que la société civile devient un acteur
politique avec lequel il faudra
travailler donc sans répondre aux
revendications de la mobilisation il
serait difficile de gérer le pays de
gérer la peau lié le gérer les affaires
du pays notamment politique mais aussi
économique et social dont le futur alors
vous tenir à démissionner dell imagine t
bouddha et et a été élu on organisait
donc des élections et pourtant le irak a
continué vous l'avez dit ça va faire un
an que doit-on y voir exactement dans
lequel à la population le irak les
revendications du lac comme l'estiment
les militants aujourd'hui les
manifestants ne sont pas satisfaites
donc l'élection a été rejetée est
rappelons le par
les manifestants beaucoup de
manifestants mais aussi donc la
légitimité romero remettant en cause la
légitimité du président actuel donc il
ya on est donc dans une sorte de pour le
moment d'un statu quo
mais en même temps tout dépendra dix
mesures qui seront prises dont le futur
je reviens bien sûr ou sur la situation
de fragilité économique du pays
bien sûr la présidence de doter boom
avait permis à l'état algérien de
revenir notamment sur la scène
internationale loin d'un retour après
bien sûr plusieurs années d'absence
mais c'est la crise politique interne
risque de fragiliser le pays risque de
fragiliser le président actuel est
compris et que ce soit sur le plan
interne ou international
d'où cette crise de conscience je pense
que dans le futur you dont le futur que
les revendications où ils sont répondre
aux revendications du rédac
il serait difficile de donc la rivière
va vous pensez que le nouveau président
va répondre aux demandes des
manifestants
il est fort possible parce que son
répondre et ce serait une défiance une
sorte de fuite en avant qui risque dans
l'avenir dont l'avenir de créer des
conditions
des conditions je dirais difficile des
sites une situation je dirais même un
gouvernant gouverneur dont la suite
parce que parce que je rappelle la
fragilité économique et social du pays
qui va nécessiter du gouvernement actuel
de prendre des mesures des mesures
drastiques d'austérité probablement
suspendre certains subvention qui
pourrait induire à l'inflation
on voit aujourd'hui l'économie qu'on
aime et vous voit une certaine
stagnation la lutte contre la corruption
kiwi d'une part anne est bonne bien sûr
mais en même temps elle crée un climat
de terreur dans le monde des affaires ce
qui ne favorise pas non plus les
investissements directs qui pourrait
relancer l'économie algérienne et créer
de l'emploi donc tout cela
le gouvernement actuel a plutôt intérêt
à apaiser les tensions à créer un climat
plutôt détendu de 2,10 à bord des deux
avec le faire alors justement le chirac
c'est un peu l'acteur majeur en ce
moment en algérie pourtant il n'y avait
pas de représentant aux dernières
élections il n'a pas vraiment de porte
parole officiel
est-ce que lors des prochaines échéances
électorales qui va arriver qui vont
arriver en algérie est ce que peut-être
nous représentants du miracle qui veut
justement être candidat exactement c'est
sur ces élections là que j'ai évoquées
récemment que je parais personnellement
sur les l'avenir du halal c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui on bien sûr on reproche à
faire là de ne pas avoir des
représentants ce qui est normal c'est un
phénomène
c'est un mouvement horizontal qui
maintient son et rose son horizontalité
pour plusieurs raisons mais aujourd'hui
bien sûr il sait il est difficile
d'avoir des représentants
je dirais légitime pour pour deux
raisons la première c'est que certains
leaders certains certains militants
émergents où sont emprisonnés donc 12 ce
qui crée la nappe heures sujet certains
mais ensuite le climat globalement
politique n'est pas favorable
là les médias sont encore fermées aux
opposants mais les élections donc je
rappelle que bien sûr action un peu loin
les élections législatives et
municipales pourraient donner naissance
à des à deux des futurs élus député
maire qui issus du frac et qu port en
lige hit man légitime légitimement bien
sûr représenté les revendications porter
les revendications de bellac et devenir
un intermédiaire un interlocuteur plus
avait du pouvoir dans le futur
merci brahim ou mons où je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant en géopolitique
chercheur associé à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'algérie merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rythme